[Musique]
m
bonsoir bienvenue en caroline constater
ce soir nous réforme de l'expression
artistique à cuba chacun connaît les
richesses de la musique cubaine mais
savez vous que la france était désert
visuels les arts contemporains et de
plus en plus développées sur l'île
alors
c'est un passage une ruelle d'à peine
200 m dans le quartier populaire de
keyyo we saw à la havane il s'appelle la
cale et crown d amel un jour de 1990 le
peintre et sculpteur savador gonzalez
décide d'exposer ses créations en plein
air et il commence par les
représentations allégoriques de la
santeria le culte afro cubains
l'artiste a toutes élaborées seul pas de
subvention ni même d'autorisation
officielle une simple tolérance au
départ mais très vite les fresques de
salvador attire de nombreux visiteurs et
la municipalité de la havane décide de
fermer la rue au véhicule et d'en faire
une attraction touristique
chaque jour bus et taxis déversent des
dizaines de touristes étonnés et
admiratifs devant ces murs décorés
jusque sur les plus hautes façades
le site s'est enrichi et la calique
rhône est aujourd'hui un véritable musée
à ciel ouvert l'assemblage hétéroclite
d'objets du quotidien reconverti et de
peintures murales et singulier tout est
art jusqu'au bien si terme sur les toits
le dimanche les nombreux visiteurs
peuvent assister à des représentations
des rythmes de la santeria avec chants
et musiques
salvador gonzalez est aujourd'hui un
artiste reconnu il expose à l'étranger
sa notoriété lui autorise quelques
audaces quelques critiques mais voilés
des conditions de vie des cubains
[Rires]
mais l'événement le plus novateur de ces
dernières années à la havane c'est la
création en 2014 de la fabrique à del
arte cubano une ancienne usine
reconvertie en espace culturel
d'avant-garde où se mêlent et cohabitent
la musique la danse la littérature le
théâtre à la mode de la photographie un
lieu unique géré par un collectif de
créateurs en portage touristes à
l'hystérie met en doute
dans la banlieue proche de la havane une
façade qui d'emblée attire l'attention
l'éclairage peu agressif interpelle
pourtant l'ancienne usine de production
d'huile est devenu aujourd'hui fabrique
d'art à cuba on l'appelle fac pour
fabriquer des arcs et kuba nous cette
vraie usine à l'arrêt peut récupérer
pour faire le projet culturel alors les
dès de début c'était dedans mélanger
tous les arts dans un lionel le même
espace en même temps
ce soir on accueille les visiteurs en
musique
ce n'est que 20 heures à 22 heures ce
sera la coupe
[Musique]
certaines soit la fréquentation peut
atteindre mille visiteurs
en achetant son billet 2 euros on ne
sait jamais vraiment de quoi sera fait
la soirée le lieu est fait pour
surprendre
et à la musique la musique classique les
concerts la danse le théâtre les
différentes performances et léa le
dessin le dessin industriel dessins
graphiques larchitecture alors tout ça
en permanence alors les gens qui
viennent ici rien parce que c'est un
lien très social
point de rencontre de la jeunesse
branchée
avec ces trois là prenons au hasard on
sait couloir qui ne mène nulle part sauf
à ses oeuvres d'art qui se laisse
scruter commenter analyser en toute
liberté
l'espace est conviviale sans contrainte
on entre en communion avec l'artiste
nous sommes ici depuis 2013 nous avons
en tout cinq navires conteneurs pour
respecter l'esprit usine vrai patrimoine
culturel et c'est dans chacun de ces
conteneurs que s'organisent les
manifestations artistiques
la fac et pluridisciplinaire
vous n'étiez pas venu dans ce but ne
vous voici happé par en cours de danse
c'est la leçon de tango pour tous quel
que soit son niveau quel que soit son
culot
[Applaudissements]
c'est un projet totalement ouvert à la
réception de tous les projets qu'ils
soient présents on
elle recevra tous les projets et à faire
hallyday de l'expo le concept incorpore
les artistes la sélection se fait en
dépendance de sujet de l'exposition
nous travaillons avec des artistes
locaux des artistes cubains et qui sont
reconnus aussi bien ici qu'à l'étranger
des jeunes artistes qui nous ont
présenté leur projet
la volonté c'est toujours d'incorporer
des nouveaux artistes et de continuer à
travailler avec les artistes qui vont
partait déjà des projets
ici le public peut aussi voir naître un
spectacle ce groupe de danse propose
d'assister à la mise au point et à la
répétition de leurs nouvelles créations
en quatre ans d'existence à peine la
fabrique d'art a acquis une réputation
internationale sur son livre d'or
figurent des signatures très
prestigieuse
par exemple nous avons eu la visite du
chanteur mick jagger à l'occasion du
passage des rolling stones l'ex première
dame des etats unis michelle obama a
rendu visite l'acteur kevin bacon le
producteur quincy jones est aussi herbie
hancock richard bona on est très fiers
que toutes ces personnalités viennent
nous voir après si et valorisant le
travail
la fac toléré par le pouvoir symbolise
l'ouverture actuelle les artistes du
monde entier peuvent solliciter les
organisateurs
aucune candidature n'étant négliger
à
travers les réseaux sociaux et par le
biais du courrier électronique les
artistes du monde entier y compris les
cubes à installer ailleurs prennent
contact avec nous et nous envoient leurs
projets et cela est pour nous très
gratifiant que depuis l'étranger les
gens soient motivés pour venir montrer
leur talent ici et bien sûr le centre
est ouvert la structure dispose de sept
mille mètres carrés barre et espaces de
restauration compris elle s'impose une
fermeture tous les 3 mois pendant un
mois pour permettre un renouvellement
total
une des choses que nous évoquons que
nous valorisons constamment
c'est l'écologie avec le thème du
recyclage des matériaux
beaucoup de ceux que l'on retrouve ici a
été récupéré même dans la rue et on a
valorisé il des choses de l'ancienne
usine
c'est aussi l'esprit du sinn avec tous
ces conteneurs où nous avons organisé
les différents espaces
idée géniale d'un collectif de créateurs
la fac a réussi son pari de devenir un
haut lieu de la vie nocturne de la
havane c'est à l'instar de ce qui se
fait à paris londres ou new york
[Musique]
et
depuis sa création en 1984 la biennale
de la havane est devenu l'un des rendez
vous artistiques les plus importants au
monde à sa création la bimr était dédiée
à la promotion des arts contemporains de
pays défavorisés principalement des
caraïbes et d'amérique latine
aujourd'hui des exposants du monde
entier y participent
le centre d'art contemporain wilfredo
lam en charge de l'organisation reçoit
pour chaque édition plusieurs centaines
de demandes d'artistes qui sont ensuite
sélectionnés
pendant la biennale tout le centre
historique de la havane se transforme en
galerie d'art géante dans une ambiance
très festive dans toutes les rues et
places de la vieille havane
en plus du programme officiel des
expositions se tiennent dans des
appartements et maisons particulières et
depuis quelques années des artistes
cubains qui avaient quitté l'île sont
revenus et ont ouvert leur propre
galette
la biennale attire de nombreux
collectionneurs étrangers et l'art
contemporain cubain s'exporte de mieux
en mieux
la vitalité du secteur incite les
artistes à se regrouper et investir de
nouveaux lieux parfois inattendus
ici on déambule au milieu des oeuvres
d'art nous sommes sur le site d'une
ancienne laverie dans le quartier très
populaire du buena vista rendu célèbre
par un groupe de musiciens des artistes
plasticiens ont installé un lieu de
rencontres et d'échangés autour de l'art
contemporain cela s'appelle la lavande
guérilla
peintures sculptures objets insolites
reconverti en oeuvre d'art cet immense
hangar ancien laverie et depuis 2012 un
espace d'exposition et de création
dans chaque recoin tableaux et objets
sont comme entreposés à peine mise en
valeur sans cesse renouvelée car le site
est vivant les artistes s'y installent
le temps de peaufiner leurs créations
dans des disciplines très différentes
peintures sérigraphie travail du bois ou
du métal ou de la fibre de verre comme
ce requin géant créé par le maître des
lieux
trouver un espace de travail confortable
mais une difficulté pour tout artiste
bas la difficulté est encore plus grande
et avoir trouvé un tel espace est
quelque chose de fabuleux
il nous a permis surtout dans mon cas de
donner plus de dimension à mon travail
comme ça est très grand je peux mieux
visualiser mon oeuvre c'est un espace
ouvert
[Musique]
depuis son ouverture la lavande guérilla
a attiré beaucoup d'artistes et le site
a aussi permis de créer du lien entre
eux et avec la population
car le quartier bonavista dans lequel se
trouve l'ancien laverie était connue
pour ses combats de rue un quartier
malfamé en dépit de sa notoriété à
l'étranger depuis le film sorti en 1999
la présence de cet espace de création
dans le quartier buena vista a changé sa
physionomie
cela était très réconfortant d'un et le
travail que nous réalisons dans un
espace social
qui n'avaient pas l'habitude de la
création artistique
il ya quelques années ce n'était qu'un
théâtre de combats de rue et c'est
devenu un lieu de paix où les gens ne
viennent pas pour s'affronter
mais pour participer à un processus
créatif
la lavande guérilla qui reste un site
privé géré par des artistes désormais
connue des guides touristiques et reçoit
de nombreux visiteurs
pas seulement des collectionneurs mais
aussi des touristes attirés par
l'originalité du lieu et cette
impression de découvrir un peu de l'âme
artistique de cuba
m
l'expression artistique à cuba ne se
cantonne pas aux lieux dédiés elle est
partout et surtout dans la rue les
endroits où les gens se rencontrent où
il se montre les cubains en particulier
les jeunes sont soucieux de leur
apparence et malgré les pénuries suivent
la mode la mode internationale
jusque dans le détail des coiffures
reportage maurice tags ou ferry
maisonneuve
dans les rues de la havane les cheveux
ça saute aux yeux
impossible de ne pas remarquer ces
coupes nouvelles tendances dont les
jeunes raffolent
entre la coupe steak ou la coupe requins
ils savent tous parfaitement faire la
différence
et c'est le regard malicieux ou amusé
qu'ils évoquent cette mode qui se veut
fun et branché
pourquoi j'ai pris une telle coupe
parce que ça me plaît c'est la mode
cette tendance
puisque les jeunes femmes à quoi j'ai
bon c'est la mode actuelle
mon coiffeur m'a montré des photos j'ai
adopté
les gels pour coiffure tout cela il faut
être à la mode les artistes les
footballeurs tout le monde s'y met moi
aussi
me l'a proposé et j'aime bien ça te
coûte un peu haras sur les bords
j'aime
moi j'aime dans le style d'un vase à
l'arrière les cheveux avec cette couleur
dorée ça me plaît
le monde entier cherchent à profiter du
charme incroyable de la femme créature
de rêve
oui coloré rythmé volupté
chaque rue une ruelle de la capitale est
une scène de théâtre un plateau de
tournage pour le cinéma ou la télévision
chanteur acteur
réalisateur
tout le monde veut trouver sa place
on va s'amuser
incontestablement cuba est à la mode
mais le cubain louis et île à la mode
peut-il suivre ce mouvement que
reste-t-il de cette coquetterie
légendaire d'avant castro qui avait fait
la réputation de la dame jusqu'en europe
1 samedi matin
une salle studieuse et attentive pour
parler ou écouter parler de la coiffure
ce n'est rien d'autre qu'une passation
thèse dans une pièce minuscule de la
vieille dame dalila doit répondre à
toutes sortes de questions du jury sur
le travail de recherche qu'elle a mené
une séance très technique entre
spécialistes la jeune fille joue son
avenir professionnel
tout simplement je voulais que tout le
monde apprécie ce type de transformation
que je peut opérer sur envisage un parc
de mes propres modèles
et c'est un vrai succès parce que je ne
pensais pas être si convaincante
ils ont beaucoup aimé tous ces photos
que j'ai proposées sur ces photos il y a
plusieurs modèles de coiffure qui
plaisait beaucoup et ils vont les
utiliser ici pour monter une exposition
on a créé beaucoup de centres
d'aigrettés de salons de coiffure peu
partout à la 20e' ce soit tout ce qu'on
a fait rouler travail incroyable
beaucoup d'entre eux ont le standard
international
en ce qui concerne la formation les
équipages
beaucoup de gens ont le souci
d'utiliser des produits de qualité
qu'ils n'apparaissent que tout cela
fonctionne merveilleusement bien
et selon moi c'est très appréciable même
atteint le niveau de l'art
et cet homme tenait à féliciter la toute
nouvelle lauréate lui c'est papy tôt
on dira que c'est le maître des lieux
le patron de cette rouille que l'on
appelle maintenant l'allée des coiffeurs
elle callejón développer look et rios
un coiffeur au crâne rasé qui est devenu
une référence à la havane
[Musique]
lui et c'est un très bon coiffeur
quand j'étais petit c'est lui qui me
coûtait les jeux parce que je dis des
mille
îles à 96 ans et il continue à couper
les cheveux
depuis que son activité coiffure a
basculé dans le domaine privé il a su en
faire bénéficier tout son entourage
transformant la rue en au milipol
d'activité nous grimpons dans son salon
et découvre une sorte de musée
[Musique]
la passion que j'ai pour la coiffure est
en lien avec ma propre histoire
c'est la coiffure qui m'a permis de
réaliser
[Applaudissements]
professionnellement et humainement
je me suis toujours préoccupé de la
place de la coiffure dans l'histoire
finale au final le plus important
aujourd'hui est de partager tout cela
est cet endroit ne m'appartient pas il
appartient au patrimoine culturel cube
est au coiffeur du nombre
[Musique]
en plein centre de la havane cette école
suscite une certaine curiosité
les parents et les amis des élèves mais
aussi quelques passants s'y attarde e
volontiers
[Musique]
des dizaines de jeunes filles défilent
pendant des heures sous le regard de
leurs professeurs ghislaine
[Musique]
c'était pas mon toit woerth à tous ceux
qui veulent apprendre le mannequinat
même s'il ne s'agit pas forcément de
devenir un des mannequins professionnels
on est ici pour apprendre à se sentir à
l'aise dans l'agir on enseigne plusieurs
disciplines il a des cours théoriques
c'est un projet communautaire qui permet
de s'épanouir nous avons des enfants des
adolescents et les adultes on a aussi
des mannequins professionnels
alors tout le monde profite de cette
école
à cuba on s'est fixé pour objectif
d'atteindre un standard international
dans toutes les disciplines de la mode
[Musique]
à la havane quand on est à la mode il
faut venir se montrer ici sur l'avenue
23 la fameuse cai yên dit ''très le
défilé permanent l'air de rien on passe
y exhiber sa dernière petite trouvaille
il se dit que la cubaine aujourd'hui
s'habille comme elle peut en fonction de
ses faibles moyens
pourtant le résultat est souvent
bluffant
[Musique]
moi j'aime la mode je ne pourrais pas
vivre sans ce alain jund cible style des
artistes je cherche sur internet chez ce
qui se fait la mode c'est ce qui arrive
120 et revient
c'est difficile parce que nous n'avons
pas tous le pouvoir économique
on nous payait tel pantalon de telma
c'est plutôt
[Musique]
je crois qu'il ya quand même certaines
possibilités le fait vrai que les prix
sont un peu élevées alors c'est
difficile de suivre la mode
suivre la mode ça revient cher
c'est comme tout ici et on doit en même
temps c'est un jeu pour être à la mode
parce que tout le monde ne peut pas la
suivre et on s'efforce d'être au top
mais le plus important c'est ce que tu
crées qui te convient de sorte que c'est
la mode c'est celle que tout fait
bien que nous soyons un pays pas très
bien développée économiquement
nous arrivons à produire de beaux
vêtements bien dessiné
wallon desseigne même sur ce marché il
ya des artisans qui font des choses à la
main avec peu de moyens et tout cela
quand même de la lèze
oui je pense que la malle à cuba ont des
toilettes et
qualité depuis deux ans la mode cubaine
dispose d'une revue de qualité
gars bossent qui veut dire élégant sont
espagnols est une publication digital
exclusivement qui se propose de fournir
via le web une tribune à tous les
stylistes de lille
[Musique]
à
singer des ça commençait ainsi avec un
grain et des relations amicales c'est
ainsi que carbo s'agrandit
et aujourd'hui c'est devenu une revue
très connu
la seule vraie cubaine consacré à la
mode et au style de vie
les photos ont beaucoup d'impact sur nos
lecteurs car ils sont exceptionnels nous
avons la chance de collaborer avec de
très bons photographes et nous avons
atteint largement notre vue et même au
delà
[Musique]
en peu de temps la revue a acquis une
solide réputation même au plan
international au point d'avoir été
sollicité au plus haut niveau
[Musique]
gars bossent c'est la relève qui est
tous sélectionnés par chanel
lors de son défilé de mode à cuba
et nous avons vécu une expérience
géniale
nous avons appris beaucoup de choses
bien sûr
cela a été difficile bénéfique
nous avons fait une session de photos
avec eux nous ont invités au défilé et
nous gardons le contact
le magazine français elle nous a
interviewé est véritablement ça a été
une belle aventure
sur cette même avenue du prado où
défilaient les mêmes qu'un de chamelle
il y a quelques mois la vie a repris un
déroulement moins féerique
mais depuis peu la mode française il ya
trouvé son enseigne permanent
voici la boutique guerlain
en fait une renaissance car les locaux
existait déjà il ya 100 ans mais avec la
révolution l'activité parfums il a été
stoppé et les locaux ont servi à
d'autres usages mais ils avaient été
préservés et retrouve aujourd'hui toute
leur splendeur d'antan et a cassé cette
maison a été rénovée et les murs à sont
d'origine
ils ont exactement 100 ans
laval a retrouvé aujourd'hui le rôle
qu'elle a joué il ya très longtemps
c'est une sorte de laboratoire pour
juger à la danse comment les nouveautés
seront perçues dans toute l'amérique
latine
c'est ce que monsieur guerlain faisait
il ya des siècles et on le fait à
nouveau
dans cette boutique le pli petit flacon
de parfum représente l'équivalent de un
voire deux mois de salaire moyen
pourtant
incroyable paradoxe depuis l'ouverture
de l'antenne il y a 6 mois des
responsables constatent que leur
clientèle est principalement cubaine
le parfum joue un rôle très important
souvent se parfume en se disant je vais
peut-être faire aujourd'hui la culture
des mavs y
être personne va se dire c'est grâce à
ce parfum aujourd'hui je vais pouvoir
décrocher un boulot c'est comme une
tradition qui s'impose aux cubains et
sans et pour cela il va économiser et
avec l'aide qui reçoit de sa famille
vivant à l'étranger aux états unis et
puis l'énergie hausse de plus de ces
entrepreneurs privés et la nouvelle
source de revenus ce sont les cubains
les principaux clients de cette boutique
quelques centaines de mètres plus loin
le premier hôtel international cinq
étoiles de cuba vient d'ouvrir ses
portes l'hôtel manzana en plus de ces
chambres luxueuses possède une galerie
commerciale qui propose des marques de
luxe les cubains s'y aventurent sur la
pointe des pieds comme pou voir de plus
près le rêve encore inaccessibles
retour à la vieille havane dans la roue
des coiffeurs
le projet de capitaux comporte volet
formation
[Musique]
vous
ce stage de coiffure est réservé
exclusivement aux sourds muets c'est la
dimension sociale du projet
[Musique]
j'adore travailler dans ce salon à ce
que je rende les filles très belle ainsi
elles se sont dit mieux et moi aussi
on se ressemble le tout en pratique la
lecture labiale son problème on n'a
aucun problème pour se comprendre la
communication est facile
nous nous donnons une mission sociale et
nous avons cette école pour aider ces
jeunes qui évoluent dans notre société
nous enseignons l'art de la coiffure les
valeurs humaines et sociales et nous
leur fournissons du travail
alors on savoure
[Musique]
la môle kubel a son festival annuel il
se déroule ici le prestigieux théâtre
aliciens allongeant le grand théâtre de
laval pendant une semaine pas moins de
40 des filets les stylistes tibet
montrent leur savoir faire
[Applaudissements]
ici
il ya de très bon styliste qui peuvent
prétendre au niveau international
certains exercent un autre métier par
exemple mon associé et architectes et
plus souvent que rarement il enrichit la
mode vestimentaire de ses connaissances
d'architecte
moi je suis peintre j'applique l'art
plastique à l'art vestimentaire
il suffit de bouts de tissus et d'une
machine à coudre et je commence à créer
pas besoin de modèles de pas trop devant
la machine nous réalisons ce vêtement
dont nous rêvions un peu de technique et
nous pouvons refaire le monde
et de plus en plus de nu et à la havane
s'accommode de tous ces spectacles liés
à la mode
ici séance privée pour des spectateurs
triés sur le volet tous les modèles
présentés sont cubains
[Musique]
qui sait
dans les années 70-80 tout le monde
suivait la mode la mode cubaine
et pour que les gens utilisaient le
tissu des sacs de farine
[Applaudissements]
nous les cubains on ne faisait des
vêtements et c'était spectaculaire
parce qu'il s'agissait de mode cubaine
puis la mode internationale est arrivée
très bien très belle
il ya des gens qui ont su limiter
d'autres pas il y a des gens qui copie
mais quiconque humaine
dans sa boutique yamilé nous présente le
vêtement cubain par excellence la
gouaille abeba
[Musique]
cette chemise ample réputé facile à
porter adaptée au climat tropical et qui
a séduit de nombreux aficionados
jusqu en asie et à mellieha sa version
préférée sur l'origine de cette chemise
il y a plusieurs légendes la célèbre
c'est l'histoire de ces bienne - qui
aimait beaucoup les goyave d'où le nom
de voyager rhin elle demanda à sa mère
de lui confectionner une robe ce qui lui
permettrait de transporter plus de
voyages et elle lui fit un vêtement avec
4 sochaux lors chaque poche une loyale
cette chemise banni par la révolution a
été remise au goût du jour par fidel
castro qu'il utilisa pour la première
fois comme costume protocolaire en 1994
en colombie il y a plusieurs modèles il
ya le modèle classique pour ron et
ensuite cette chemise qui modernise et
les femmes ont commencé elles aussi
apporté la gouaille abers et certains
stylistes de plus en plus modifier la
gouaille abera de nos jours
on abandonne un peu le col de chemise
classique par l'école montée ou l'école
de forme ovale chinoise plus moderne qui
tiendront chaud avec des hanches longues
manches courtes sans manches
cette chemise plus tôt rejeté par les
jeunes cubains est aujourd'hui très
demandés par la clientèle touristique
les mac à la ceinture
et la force de l'âge
la rue des coiffeurs ne désemplit jamais
aujourd'hui visite d'un groupe
d'étudiants et d'entrepreneurs
américains de passage à cuba il tenait à
voir de près cette expérience car
l'initiative de papito a fait mouche et
entraîné déjà la création de dizaines
d'emplois dans plusieurs unités
c'est très intéressant car en fait je
vienne d'ukraine et on a des points
communs
j'aime bien je me sens chez moi j'ai
dédiant qu'on a fait passer de la
culture russe
donc pour moi ce n'est pas très
différent et ça va j'ai
papito le coiffeur cubain a connu son
heure de gloire c'était en mars 2016
lors d'un forum de l'entreprise à la
havane face au président américain
barack obama en visite historique dans
l'île
dans cette rue des coiffeurs qui lie à 3
à peine j'étais le seul à posséder son
entreprise
aujourd'hui 97 personnes y travaillent
en tant qu'entrepreneur prises et wind
and salariés
et cela a créé une vraie dynamique
donc je voudrais vous faire part
démontrer comment une communauté a su
engranger des profits mais aussi faire
évoluer le social
aux états-unis salon coiffure est un
élément central de la communauté c'est
un lieu de vie un lieu de rencontre
alors félicitations pour votre business
mais aussi pour l'avoir conçu comme un
levier social
qui peut contribuer au mieux être de
trouver
[Musique]
voilà voilà
pays
non
[Musique]
bon
la mode a fait des progrès à cuba elle
atteint déjà les niveaux international
et c'est pour ça que chanel est venu à
cuba
et la lune nous entrons dans les canons
de la mode internationale
nous recevons beaucoup devrions dit
annie et d'autres pays
mais aussi nous créons une mode cubaine
s'est basée sur les critères
internationaux
[Musique]
malgré le peu de ressources dont dispose
le styliste pour créer pour monter les
sélections il arrive tout de même à
faire des choses intéressantes
à partir de matériaux recyclés
des objets d'usagé courant
il part elle a créé des pièces
exceptionnelles et original
ce qui assure la cuba c'est qu'en dépit
de toutes les difficultés et les femmes
cubaines ont toujours été soucieuse leur
beauté ce que vos patients la vsc
soucieuse de suivre la mode
non seulement pour la coiffure
mais aussi pour la vie mort et cela au
fil des ans un prix d'efforts et de
sacrifices hors du commun
comment
[Musique]
cuba 20 tradition de couturière de
proximité
avant 1959
beaucoup de femmes s'habillaient à
partir de ce qu'elle pouvait reproduire
[Musique]
elle allait dans les grandes boutiques
copier les modèles se procurer le tissu
et grâce à la couture domestique
reproduisaient les modèles et des gens
obtenait quelque chose de similaire
après la révolution beaucoup de ces
femmes dû se plier aux règles du travail
social
la production domestique a été en grande
partie remplacée par une production
industrielles commercialisés dans les
magasins
et puis pendant la crise économique et
la période spéciale des années 90 les
gens de retrouver ces pratiques de la
couture de proximité pour maintenir un
certain niveau en matière vestimentaire
tout cela a du sens et nous savons qu'il
existe un important secteur qui pourrait
vivre de ce site
[Musique]
à
le
[Musique]
même le plus talentueux des stylistes
cuba se heurte à cette difficulté
majeure lié à l'embargo le manque de
matières premières
ainsi le talent la créativité
restent confidentielles
et ne connaîtront pas de sitôt
l'explosion mondiale
pourtant largement mérité
[Musique]
là
nous sommes sur le prado les champs
elysées de laval en du célèbre sur la
planète mode par karl lagerfeld qui a
organisé ici il y a un an un défilé de
haute couture depuis les professionnels
de la mode cubaine les styles d'un lob
d'accéder à cette scène internationale
où se côtoient les stars du monde entier
et les professionnels
petit à petit le secteur organisent
chaque année la semaine de la mode à la
havane se professionnalise un peu plus
le cru 2010 est a mis en relief les
trésors d'imagination déployés pour
pallier l'absence d'outils et de
matières premières reportage - ce magot
thierry maison le
[Musique]
samedi après midi alain van dans un
ancien entrepôt de tabac et de bois
ce sont des enfants et bien sûr ils
défilent avec les maladresses et
l'insouciance de leur âge
[Musique]
ils sont à cuba
cuba de répudier ème siècle qu'il compte
bien vivre à fond
c'est pour eux que cuba s'ouvre en
gardant bien les pieds sur terre
nous attendons de cet événement que
jouent les boutiques à cuba soit rempli
de vêtements de nos stylistes
[Musique]
d
il
[Musique]
d
cela fait vivre des milliers de familles
cubaines
des milliers et nous pensons vraiment
que cette secteur qui va se développer
étant nous travaillons au socialisme
prospère et durable
du 25 au 29 novembre dernier la vente
s'est offert le luxe d'une semaine de la
mort d'une fashion week à sa façon
pas pour impressionner le reste du monde
juste pour montrer qu'elle existe
80 des filets plus ou moins réussies 70
stylistes et modélistes
lui province représentait
c'est important de respecter les normes
internationales
mais nous en tant que styliste cubain si
nous travaillons à partir de ces normes
internationales c'est pour les adapter à
la réalité sociale de notre public je
les prêts seraient toujours fait la moue
nous adaptons la mode à notre climat
c'est très important et à toutes les
activités sociales auxquelles se livrent
les jeunes cubains et le reste de la
population dans son ensemble
[Musique]
que c'est très important que le terme de
la mode et des vêtements soient adaptés
aux aspirations de ceux qui les portent
[Musique]
là
m la collection était ma collection
évoque la paix j'utilise la couleur
blanche c'est un clin d'oeil à la mode
planétaire ces choses merveilleuses que
l'on soit sur terre
sur la faille la dr et comme je les dis
déjà j'ai défilé en plusieurs lieux
comme à new york ou à la semaine de la
mode des bermudes et ailleurs c'est le
message de paix qu'en tant que cubains
nous voulons faire passer à travers
notre travail
[Applaudissements]
allez
et au moment où le second est annoncée
c'est l'amour et les potards pour le
moment la mode est importé les gens
s'habillent beaucoup avec ce qui arrive
de l'extérieur les vêtements envoyé par
exemple par la famille
et nous voulons imposer notre propre
mode
mais sur excessif de penser que nous
allons effrayant c'est la mode dans la
caraïbe on pourrait y parvenir sans
aucun doute mais je pense au contraire
que c'est la caraïbe qui peut nous
influencer
[Musique]
comme pour
et
m
cela
[Musique]
célestin
ouah
deux sèvres
pour l'instant c'est à sélestat
ceux qui ont un peu d'expérience à
l'étranger savent que les conditions de
travail à offrir dans ce type
d'événement internationale nous ne
pouvons pas le garantir pour l'instant
alors nous nous appliquons à consolider
à monter en puissance à convaincre les
amis de nous aider
mais c'est sûr qu'au moment opportun
nous allons commencer par la carène qui
est notre zone géographique
et dans la mesure où nous aurons
développer consolider les choses non
seulement au niveau du projet mais aussi
au niveau du budget nous allons sans
aucun doute accepter des invitations
parce que cela nous intéresse que ce que
font les autres arrivent à cuba et que
ce que fait cuba aille chez les autres
[Musique]
nous avons un problème qu'il ne faut pas
perdre de vue c'est le coût élevé de
trois matières premières c'est une
réalité mais dans la mesure où une
solution pourrait être trouvée que nous
allons mieux aborder le marché
international pour l'achat de notre
matière première je crois que oui que
l'on pourra être plus compétitif et que
les prix de nos créations seront plus
abordables
chaque pays a sa propre façon de se
vêtir parce que nous sommes la caraïbe
nous avons une autre façon de nous
habiller que les européens
et dans mon propre cas je suis en train
de lancer cette mode inspirée du caftan
africain avec des chemises 13 angle
c'est une mode rendu populaire dans le
monde entier par la marque caracol
beaucoup suivent cette tendance mais
sans se l'approprier comme nous nous le
faisons
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
le slogan de la semaine
artisanat et identité pour bien
souligner que les collections présentées
mettant en valeur l'héritage africain et
espagnols de cuba
parfois la couleur la volupté et la
largeur des vêtements traditionnels
apportés par des esclaves appliqué à
cuba ou alors l'art de tricoter à
l'éguille éviter des espagnols
[Musique]
notre but a toujours été de travailler
pour la masse pour le plus grand monde
nous ne cherchons pas une clientèle
d'élite mais la majorité c'est le
concept que nous développons et que nous
défendons donc travailler pour une
grande quantité de personnes pas pour
les élire les à l'occasion des défilés
on essaie de faire un mix parce que
c'est un événement les créateurs
essaient de faire quelque chose de
différent et de ce fait à partir d'une
robe de prêt-à-porter simple on va vers
à un vêtement plus élaborée plus
élégants pour ses sorties nocturnes dont
on a bien besoin dans la carène
la caraïbe bien sûr fait partie du monde
de la mode
et dans chaque île il y a une approche
différente quant à la façon de
s'habiller
c'est très intéressant ces pays de la
caraïbe où l'on trouve encore ses fans
très élégante vêtue de flanelle pour se
rendre à la messe
j'ai eu l'occasion de voir en martinique
des femmes très bien habillé de jour
comme de nuit et ailleurs dans la
caraïbe à cuba au venezuela par tous
[Musique]
et
m
dm
[Musique]
pour lui
m
l'organisateur de cette manifestation
dit avoir trouvé l'inspiration chez nos
voisins de sainte-lucie invité un défilé
de mode à castries en marge du festival
de gaz il a pu apprécier la qualité de
l'organisation et des prestations
[Applaudissements]
nous avons été surpris du bon niveau
d'organisation pour un si petit pays et
par la présence de civils de toutes les
régions de la carène
et nous avons pris conscience de notre
potentiel et de la nécessité qu à cuba
peut-être comprendre étape de s'intégrer
dans la caraïbe
c'est la région qui nous touche
géographiquement et je pense que nous
pouvons accueillir ce type de
manifestation à cuba
je sais qu'il y a à l'unesco cette
volonté de promouvoir ce site des
changes nous sommes prêts à échanger
avec nos homologues de la caraïbe et en
fin de compte ce que nous travaillons
c'est la mode dans la caraïbe la mode
qui selon l'unesco une expression de vie
des habitants de ces îles
[Musique]
l'unesco fait partie des sponsors de
l'événement avec un financement pour sa
diffusion numérique et cinématographique
[Musique]
la mode cubaine qui avait commencé à
renaître dans les décennies des années
80 avait presque disparu avec la crise
économique de 90
elle revient maintenant lentement
[Musique]
et
je suis
[Musique]
m
c'est
cb
[Musique]
je suis
à cuba on considère désormais que la
mode est important comme besoin de
l'être humain au delà de tout frivolité
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
comment découvrir cuba sans être
accompagnée par sa musique la musique
cubaine est connu partout dans le monde
grâce à des films et grâce à des
musiciens célèbres d'hier et
d'aujourd'hui
raul passe et un de ses musiciens
auteurs compositeurs qui font la
renommée de cuba
[Musique]
ces moments on est à trôner fait la
musique d'un film d un film de 90
minutes et chili à un espèce de film
historique c'est aussi des choses que
j'ai fait j'ai fait beaucoup ces
derniers temps des musiques pour deux
des séries télé des musiques pour des
films des musiques la danse
contemporaine aussi
donc on la réalise la première partie
c'est le premier enregistrement de la
musique d d un film de 90 minutes de
cuba à l'extérieur on connaît la musique
traditionnelle surtout quand on est ici
on entend du reggaeton c'est quoi la
musique cubaine aujourd'hui
la musique huvelle aujourd'hui c'est la
musique de toujours a fait c'est un
mélange des choses et ces mélanges des
choses à nos amis à la musique
traditionnelle mais ça nous amène aussi
aux log étonne que c'est la musique plus
contemporaine un peu plus aux rebelles
mais ça nous amène à l'albatros ça nous
amène à lens on a le plus traditionnel
mais ça nous amène aussi d'inde et la
musique électronique d'aujourd'hui à
cuba cuba c'est si un vivier de la bible
et qui a constant à bully sion et
mouvements du bassin un pays qui
aujourd'hui même dans le social ou
politique ou culturelle et il est en
train de se retrouver il ya des
explosions de partout mais à ce moment
il ya une vraie explosion du véloce il
s'arme peut les voir dans des endroits
comme la fabrique alerte et comment
l'avant de dire voilà c'était plus serré
style de
l'artiste peintre qui s'est mis à
travailler ensemble des musiciens qui se
met à travailler avec des artistes
parlent ou du ou des écrivains ou de la
danse contemporaine
je pense que la grosse pression dès ce
moment c'est de s'unifier il y à il ya
quelque chose qui se passe mais c'est
comme les pays où c'est parce qu'il
avait passé des mains on sait pas où ça
va mener il ya un bon moment d
unification certaine façon de se
retrouver pour unifier et d'affronter
des nouvelles tenues
[Musique]
en cette période de fin d'année et les
touristes se font nombreux à cuba une
présence en augmentation constante même
si les récentes mesures de restriction
prises par donald trump ont déjà des
conséquences sur la fréquentation des
touristes américains
avec plus de 4 millions de visiteurs en
2016 cuba est une destination très
prisée mais cette année avec l'arrivée
de trump au pouvoir les américains sont
déjà un peu moins nombreux un reflux
largement compensé par les canadiens et
les européens espagnols en premier lieu
et les français cuba est la quatrième
destination long-courrier des compagnies
françaises
l' architecture de la vieille havane un
pays à forte culture et l'identité une
histoire politique devenu légende et qui
s'écrit encore attire les visiteurs et
tout est fait pour les accueillir même
si les rues pleines de charme se
transforme parfois en pièges à touristes
où chacun est décidé à tirer profit de
cette manne
le gouvernement cubain a choisi de faire
du tourisme locomotive de l'économie et
les constructions d'hôtels surtout de
luxe se multiplient
le groupe français bouygues bien
implanté à cuba à en chantier plusieurs
établissements de haut standing 22 au
total sur l'ensemble de l'île
108 mille chambres sont prévues d'ici
2030 au lieu de 67 mille aujourd'hui
est déjà partout les prix s'envolent
mais en dehors des hôtels de luxe le
confort reste sommaire dans certains
établissements de moyenne gamme qui
n'ont jamais été rénové
l'accroissement des logement chez
l'habitant et des appartements
entièrement dédié à la location
touristique diversifiée l'hébergement
mais dans un pays où le salaire moyen
est de 26 euros par mois les inégalités
se creusent entre ceux qui ont accès aux
touristes et les autres
au delà des hôtels cubain à des projets
de parcs à thème de golf et de
développement du secteur croisière
presque toutes les grandes compagnies
sont déjà là et l'escale cubaine est un
must sur les catalogues des
croisiéristes
nous arrivons au terme de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi toute l'équipe de
caraïbes vous souhaite de joyeuses fêtes
à très bientôt pour de nouveaux
reportages bonsoir
[Musique]
ce
pas
[Musique]
à
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à
m
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
tous
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]